-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Alan Cumming
I want I want to add something
to the last story,
I feel like if I were Kriste
the rest of my life, I would d
that for all funerals.
So that no one would know
it was a mistake.
-That's we have a pact,
she and I do.
Whoever dies first,
the other one's going to sen
a basket of muffins, no,
it's definitely going to happen.
-That's a good, that's good.
-You guys are doing
a Broadway cruise together
-Yes, it's a we are.
I don't know why I'm laughing.
But it's a cruise
and Broadway fans get to go on
and meet the stars
and we sing,
but I'm doing
a concert in dry dock.
-Oh, gotcha.
-I'm not going on the cruise
-So you're going to go
on that physical boat.
You're going to sing,
perform, get lost.
-Yes, I'm going. And then they
go to Bermuda or somewhere
-And now is that
because you don't --
this did not interest you
to be on the high seas.
-Um, well, no,
I'm quite a good sailor,
if that's what you're
referring to, but no, I don't.
-You're quite a good sailor?
-Yes, I do enjoy a sail.
-Really?
-Yeah.
And I love going on a cruise
I love -- I've been on acros
the Atlantic several times
-Have you really?
-I love it.
-To travel or for like vacation?
Like have you ever done it
like, "I need to go
over there anyway."
-Well, like, if I --
I have actually.
If you have enough time
and if the dates work,
I'd rather do that
than take a plane.
-Yeah.
-I've done it maybe
two or three times,
but it's so,
it's so like another world
you kind of get on
and the plane let you go
for piano recitals.
And it's not like I mean
I think most people's
perception of cruises
is kind of tacky and show bi
and lots of and COVID
and everything, you know.
-Show biz and COVID.
-Yes, show biz and COVID.
But this is it's very sort o
like another
another world.
-That's lovely.
Between the Cunards thanks
-This is very exciting.
You have your own
place club coming,
which is a cabaret space,
and it is open again.
And you actually did your --
were you went there
after your premiere.
-Yes. That's no doubt that's
just about the premiere.
Cecily sang "The Man Who Got
Away" beautifully.
-She just has a beautiful
singing voice.
-And DeVoné lovely Dove Cameron,
do you know her?
-I don't.
-She's so nice.
She's like she's a young
actress and singer
and she's been on
all these Disney things.
And she's just
she's fascinating, actually.
She's fascinating to me.
And we have a little such.
I think she's got, like,
a daddy crush on me,
which I quite enjoy.
And I have a daddy crush back.
And we sang
the "Part of Your World"
from "The Little Mermaid."
-Great.
-Which I think is
a great song to sing.
In a public setting.
-Oh, no,
I think it always
brings down the house.
-Because everybody --
it's one of these songs.
Everybody knows the words
but often pretends not to.
You know, that's the thing
I think in America especially,
people sort of
don't want to admit
they know the sort of "perceived
to be tacky" songs.
But what was hilarious
at one size,
I always think that
at Club Cumming
because also it's got
a question and answer thing.
You know, "What's a fire and why
does it, what's the word again?"
Like she can't remember,
but and you go "Burn!" anyway.
So there was one time
I was doing that
and there was one of
later at Club Cumming
it's, you know, shows,
but then it becomes
more dance-y and deejays.
and so there was
a gogo boys and girls.
So there's a Google boy
called Mariano, who's lovely
He's moved to L.A. now,
but anyway he was there
in his jockstrap
waiting to start dancing.
And there's me like granddad
singing "Part of Your World.
And when it got to that bit,
I went, "What's a fire and
and why does it,
what's the word again?"
And I gave him the mic, like
that for him to go "Burn!"
But he thought
I meant to introduce himself
so he went "Mariano."
So not so.
No now at Club Cumming,
seriously,
every single time anyone
ever sings "Part of Your World,"
all of the audience shouts out
"Mariano."
-Oh, that's crazy.
-And a girl sang it in Mandarin.
-I heard a girl singing it
in Mandarin one night,
and everyone still shouted
out "Mariano.
-That's fantastic.
-I like it. I like tradition
-You talked about,
Kristen couldn't go
because she had to save
her voice and had a show.
I heard you learned
from Cyndi Lauper
a voice-saving trick.
-Seriously saves my life.
Really?
-I ain't gonna swear there
but yes, it's well, it was I
was doing The Threepenny Opera
with her my only other musical
I've done apart from "Cabaret.
And it's very difficult
playing Mack the Knife.
It's a really big singing part
and I was having --
I got a sore throat.
And so I went
to her singing teacher
and she's this lady
called Katie Agresta.
And her specialty
is it's like rock stars
who scream in stadiums
every night and she gets -
So what you do
is you pull your tongue ou
with a piece of paper towe
because basically when you
horse is just means your tongu
is wound up to tightly at th
bone at the back of your throat.
It's a game changer.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-How long do you pull it out
-When you pull out and you g
get these different things
you pull it, you smile, yo
gi-hee-hee, gi-hee
up and down the scale,
and then you go gi-i-i.
And then you giii, up a thir
and down about 20 minutes.
I know it's funny and crazy.
I'm sensing your cynicism.
I said I liked it
without the audience.
Now I want the audience back
they would be cheering at this
-They'd be like look what he
does for us!
-Right?
-But this crew.
-I know.
-Ugh. Trust me.
-A little snicker that was
-You have an advantage over me
when this is over,
you get to leave.
-You've got to stay and be
mocked mercilessly
by those little people
in the dark.
-Oh, they won't give us
their name.
-That's right.
-So, uh --
-So anyways, it's a good lik
20 minutes of that.
I've been like some mornings
you know, wake up in a hotel
think "Oh, [bleep]
the voice is not so good."
Got to do a concert tonight.
20 minutes. Boom.
-Wow.
-Yes. It's excellent.
-Um, I think of one thing that
a lot of people turn to
during this pandemic
were podcasts.
You've got a couple.
-Yes.
-You have one
that's about shelves
and what people have
on their shelves.
-Well, it's about my shelves
-Your shelves?
-Called Alan Cumming's Shelves
-Okay.
-So I have all these shelves
with I'm slightly hoard-y.
I kind of take weird thing
that I, you know,
not always like memento,
but momentous for me,
random little things
and I and I --
So I was in the, in the,
the beginning of the pandemic.
I was thinking, oh,
I remember that story
that I thought that would be
a really good podcast.
So I take something
from the shelves
and then I talk about it
and then I get someone
who's involved in
my memory of it,
so it's always people I know
And I then tell the story
and then so I did --
I've done, I've done about 1
now that have gone out.
And I did one my friend,
Monica Lewinsky,
she gave me this award.
And so it was about the awards
I was clinking the awards
you could hear.
But we were laughing
because it was Emmy weeken
and it's just when she was
just kind of coming back
into life again, into society.
And it was really lovely.
Anyway, that night went to thi
party at our agents' at CAA,
one of those ones,
and one with three letters
And they, and it
was in a restaurant
and they didn't bring food
You had to go into the kitchen
to get food yourself.
It was like, you know,
whatever happened to waiters
And so we were really hungry
and there was no pizzas left
but they had these baguettes
So I said,
could I have this baguette
And the man was like, "Sure.
So Monica and I,
I got a baguette.
She didn't take one.
And she went to the loo
and I went to the bar
and I was I hold up my baguett
so you can see me.
So I did that.
Then we were leaving
and trying to go out
and I was bopping people
on the shoulder with my baguette
to get them out.
And it was really useful.
And then when we got out to th
thing, it was all valet's
and everyone's car coming
it was a mess.
And there was police there
and everything.
And I could we could see
Monica's car,
but he couldn't see us.
So I went up and I bopped
my baguette
on the window of the car
and the policeman
with a loudhailer
who has a loudhailer anymore
I went, "Sir, sir,
would you stop hitting
that car with your breadstick?
-I was going to be shocked
If the cop had said baguette
I would have been like
"This story's not real."
-That was yeah.
I just I was like, really?
I thought, gosh,
I'm going to get arrested
for hitting a car
with with some French bread.
-I mean, if there's any crim
that we should look
the other way on,
it's hitting a car with bread.
-I'm ready for that. Yeah.
-You have a show coming out on
is what is it, HBO Max?
-HBO Max.
Yes, it's another it's calle
"The Prince."
-"The Prince."
That's really exciting.
-It's an anima-- It is.
It's hilarious.
It's an animated show
written by Garry Gianetti
and it's about started off
on Instagram,
him sort of doing
these sort of witty things
about Prince George,
Little Prince George.
I know it's an animated thin
and I play
Prince George's valet.
-Oh, fantastic.
-Yeah, it's it's it's biting
and hilarious.
-So I can't wait for that.
-Yeah.
-Congrats on "Scmigadoon."
It's so lovely to have you here.
Thanks for making the time
-Yeah. It was really nice.
-I really appreciate it.